one specific question that you brought
up you said he was only talking to Jews
and I just want you to just hone in on
that for a second uh two-part question
was it only Jews around him straight up
and then number two in your expert
opinion did Jesus mean to start a new
religion the most important thing the
most important fact to understand about
Jesus when trying to figure out who he
was and what he was talking about is
that he was a Jew preaching Judaism to
other Jews this was not a new religion
there was nothing new about what he was
preaching it was Judaism and he was
preaching it in Jewish terms he was
preaching it in Aramaic was he speaking
Hebrew Aramaic what was his Hebrew was
was an educated uh language so he may
have he may have understood Hebrew when
it was spoken like when if someone read
the the Hebrew scriptures he could have
he probably could have understood it but
he wouldn't communicate in Hebrew he
would communicate in Aramaic which is
the language of the poor and
he was speaking to other poor Jews he
was a poor Jew preaching Judaism to
other poor Jews
once you understand that that and that's
not disputed right that's that's sort of
a very basic understanding of of the
gospels once you understand that then it
opens a door to understanding what it is
that he's actually saying right how
would these poor Jews understand these
words he's not talking to you he's not
talking to me right he's not he's not
preaching Christianity
he's a Jew preaching Judaism what was so
radical about what he was preaching to
Jews because you've used that word he
was a radical he was right you know he
was he had all these crazy ideas but if
he was preaching Judaism to other Jews
what was so radical about that well
Judaism like all religions comes in a
hundred different flavors right right
we've already talked about it with
Catholicism uh the Judaism of first
century Palestine had a bunch of
different flavors there was the temple
Judaism the Judaism that was controlled
by the Jewish authorities that was
involved that involved very uh
restrictive extraordinarily expensive
Temple uh rituals that all Jews were
forced uh to do at least once a year if
not more
and that was a business it was a it was
a business decision governed by the
Parish government governed by the
Pharisees yeah and the Sadducees and
they and they controlled the temple and
since the temple was the source of
Salvation they controlled salvation
right if they could tell you that you
were a Jew or not a Jew right because
they controlled the thing where God
literally dwelled
then there was this sort of pharisaic
Judaism which eventually becomes what we
know as rabbinic Judaism right the the
the the Judaism of the law right the
scholars the thinkers The Debaters and
that like as you can imagine ran the
gamut right very conservative
views much more sort of innovative
interpretations of the Torah and the law
and then there were thousands upon
thousands of charismatic Street
Preachers like Jesus many of whom call
themselves Messiah many many oh yes yes
yes yes yes we know I say in in Zealot
we know the names of at least 12. if we
know the names of at least 12 then there
were 1200
um of people who said that they were the
Messiah people who said they were the
Messiah who led Messianic movements who
had far far more followers than Jesus
ever did so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]